うわぁこれじゃあ肇社長で崔議員バスケットボールにハマっていてお前も
バスケットボールするためだけに東京に行ってきました
たぶんこの動画を見てる人ではバスケットボールをうまくなりたいと思ってる人もいる
と思うてバスケットボール理由なるために夏市内で必要になるのは2つを受け取ること
みんな払
あってきたら怖いよね僕は最初は怖かった先輩から流れるキラーボール何人の人が
突き指したか病院送りになった人もいたよ
そうバスケットのシェアにおいてもっとももっとも米中とヘ妻たちのバスケットにで
求められるのは舅なんだが中とかでいくと見てればパスを行う必要があるんだ
こういう感じねで多分バスケット初めてやる人はパンツを学んだ難しいし
ハイパスけど
ちょっと怖いので今回僕はちょっと研究を重ねて誰でも確実にどんなパスでも受け取る
ことができるようになる
トレーニング方法を見つけましたこれを実践すればこの動画を見ている君君はどんな
パスでも受け取ることができる最強のバスケットボールプレイヤーになれ
今日は早速それを実践していこうと思うよで aiko
バケットロールっていうのは何
が強いかというとパスのミスへたまにものすごい場所にパスをしてくる人もいるよね
でも試合中はそんなこと言ってられないどんなパスでも取らなきゃいけないんだ
どんな場所にパスが来ても受け取るような練習をしてれば良いと思ったので僕は今
こちら
海庵で階段にぶつかることによってあらゆるランダム性が起きてしまう
16段の階段があるのでこのずう六段の階段が俺なんかバスケットボールは何を思うか
というといろんな閣下降れ覚醒これ
なった一番所に僕がいるんですけど到達それまでにどんな動きになってるかは読めない
がその客しなければいけないこれを振り返ることによってどんなパスにも対応できる
サイ
今日の
あのーボールキャッチャーになりますいや混ぜこれベースしたらまず県先発からまで
行ってると思う
よし今おっっ
はあああ
まあこういうことな
なんか違うこれを繰り返しだけです本当に
ブルーああああああああああああああ
voodoo
4ポスカ
その通りだろそれ麻雀
う
あっはぁああっえっ
ban
はぁ
何のご報告じゃあ上げてわざと速度を上げたかなとよりアグレッシブなパスが
受け取れるようになります
ん
10分
ああああああああああああああ
狙った感じではなくてよかったまあここまでは問題でこれた
さらなるパスをキャッチしたい見えない最終ステップとしてボールを2つこれが者から
の
これは2つなボールの位置に広めなきゃいけないからディフェンスをペイントでもなり
ます広い視野を持つことによってお皿にオフェンスディフェンスに幅が広がる
そういう練習法になってますかつえボールのキャッチ力もつくやっていま
されています
ああああああ
ああああああああ
んわー
re
[拍手]
me
uh
うううう
car
uh